ابرز التطورات الميدانيه لحرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا قالت مصادر رميدانيه للجزيره ان
القوات الاوكرانيه تصدت لرتل لرتل روسيا
كبير حاول استعاده مناطق السيطره عليها
الجيش الاوكراني في محور بخ كما بثت مواقع
اوكرانيه صورا لما قالت انه تدمير رتل
عسكري روسي كان يحاول التقدم باتجاه محور
بدورها افادت قياده عمليات المنطقه
الشرقيه في اوكرانيا انها صدت عده هجمات
روسيه في مختلف محاور
واضافت ان المدفعيه الاوكرانيه استهدفت
مخازن اسلحه ونقاط تجمع للافراد الروس في
مناطق واسعه
قال المتحدث باسم قياده العمليات الشرقيه
الاوكرانيه
ان قوات بلاده هي التي تبادر في ساحه
المعركه في منطقه بخموت واكد المتحدث ان
القوات الاوكرانيه احرز التقدم ونعل
الاطراف الشماليه والجنوبيه لباخموت
وتقدمت مسافه اكثر من كيلو متر خلال اليوم
الماضي
مازلنا نمتلك زمام المبادره في اتجاه
بخموت وننفذ هجمات ونتقدم على طول
الجناحين الشمالي والجنوبي خلال اليوم
الماضي تم التقدم لاكثر من كيلومتر دمرنا
عددا من الاليات والمعدات الروسيه
ومستودعات ميدانيه للذخيره يقاوم المحتلون
الهجوم الاوكراني واحيانا ينفذون هجمات
مضاده محدوده ولكن بشكل عام نحن من يبادر
ويتقدم الى الامام رغم اننا وهذه حقيقه لا
نمتلك ميزه التكافؤ في القوه والموارد
في روسيا افادت خدمات الطوارئ بسقوط سته
قتلى وجريحين في انفجار في مصنع للمواد
المتفجره في مدينه السماره وسط البلاد
وقالت خدمات الطوارئ ان الانفجار نتج عن
تفكيك بعض المعدات واجراء تصطيحات في
المصنع ميدانيا قال موقع ريبار العسكري
الروسيين القوات الروسيه صدت محاولات هجوم
للجيش الاوكراني على مواقع في بلده
بيرخوفكا شمال بخموت واستعاده سيطرتها على
سد بيرخوفكا المجاور
كما افاد الموقع بان الجيش الروسي صد
هجمات اوكرانيه قرب مدينه اريخوف
فيزابيلوجيا
في هذه الاثناء قالت السلطات المواليه
لروسيا في دنيا كنا خمسه مدنيين على الاقل
اصيبوا بجروح في قصف اوكرانيا على المناطق
الخاضعه للسيطره الروسيه واضافت السلطات
المواليه لروسيا ان القوات الاوكرانيه
قصفت احياء في دنيتك ومدن غور لوفكا
وبلدات مجاوره باكثر من 120 قذيفه خلال
الاربع وعشرين ساعه الماضيه
قال الرئيس الاوكراني
لن تستطيع القيام بهجومها المضاد دون
اسلحه هجوميه متطوره تتضمن صواريخ بعيده
المدى واضاف في تصريحات له في العاصمه
التشيكيه انه يجب الاسراع في ضمن اوكرانيا
الى الاتحاد الاوروبي
رئيس وزراء تشيك ان مستقبل اوكرانيا في
الاتحاد الاوروبي والنيتو مضيفا انه يتوقع
ان يدعم الشركاء في الحلف انضمام على حد
التعبير
من جهتين انه يتابع عن كثب المفاوضات
المرتقبه اليوم بين رئيس التركي
والاوكراني لمعرفه ما ستتم مناقشته وبشان
امكانيه عقد لقاء بين الرئيس الروسي
والتركي قريبا قال الكرملين ان الاتصالات
بين الرئيسين غير مستبعده في المستقبل
المنظور
الكريم اوضح ان التسويه السياسيه
والدبلوماسيه في اوكرانيا غير ممكنه حاليا
بسبب عدم رغبه كييف وواشنطن في ذلك حسب
قوله واشار الى ان موسكو لم تغلق الباب
امام عمليه التفاوض ولكنها لا ترى اي افاق
لها حتى الان